with two hundred and fifty thousand  dollars on the line and the road to the  finals tournament about to unfold we are  excited to announce to K Street casts 2k  stream cast allows NBA 2k players to  spectate games both in progress and ones  that have finished on May twenty first  we will turn on the road to the finals  tournament treat for all 2k players as  the games progress you will be able to  hop in life and watch a game stream  directly from your console once the  matchup is ended it will be on demand  for your viewing pleasure we are excited  to debut this new technology and have  NBA 2k fans around the world be able to  watch live our road to the finals a  single elimination tournament on May  21st good luck to all our teams and  remember the entire world is now  watching